[Music]
tom is in grand rapids michigan hey tom
welcome to the ramsey show
thanks dave how are you doing today
better than i deserve what's up
so um
this is a question of integrity i've
paid off about sixty thousand dollars in
debt and i have just a few thousand left
three thousand on a credit card
that i'm 99 sure that i did not um that
i did not take out this credit card that
it's like an identity theft type of
thing
have you paid on it before
no i have not you not paid a dime on it
no it was on the very it was on the very
end of my debt snowball when did you
find out about it
um
about like
nine months 12 months ago why did you
not report it as identity theft then
because i'm not 100 sure about it and
when i contacted the bank to huntington
bank to get the
transaction history
i spent about a year trying to get the
transaction history and they they won't
give it to me so because they won't give
it to me i have
no idea
if i actually took it out or not so i'm
not comfortable yet going to the police
and filling out
a criminal report for a crime that might
not happen okay i'm a little bit
confused about how your life operates
where you don't know if you spent three
thousand dollars or not
yeah yeah it was it's from like five
years ago is when it was taken out and
it was taken out alongside of another
there were two credit cards taken out in
my name one was certainly me
the second one i'm 99.9 sure wasn't me
so this puts me in a place where my my
my question is if i find out that it
well i guess it doesn't matter if it was
me or not the integrity thing is
i should um i should just pay it off
it's my name i should be responsible for
my name you're not responsible for
identity theft
not morally not under any definition of
integrity
those people are bank robbers you're not
responsible for them robbing the bank
so then
it sounds to me like you're leaning
towards the option that i'm
my integrity is trying to tell me to
lean away from and that's what the banks
you have a wrong definition of integrity
sir
if someone else robs a bank it is not
your job to make the bank whole
that is not integrity
they robbed the bank someone robbed a
bank of three thousand dollars just
because they used your name to do it
doesn't make you liable
um i think you're feeling guilty for
being so disorganized five years ago
that you're not even sure if this is
yours no no it's not a feeling of guilt
at all it's like a thing of uh
i think that our country lacks integrity
and i think i don't disagree with that
if you told me you if you told me you
had uh
if you told me you
had taken this loan out i would tell you
to pay it as a matter of integrity but
you didn't take the loan out is what
you're telling me i mean 99.9
is kind of like a hundred
okay well let me give you just a just a
real brief backstory at the time that
this happened i was living in a really
bad area of town that was overrun by
gangs because i was house-sitting
a house for somebody
for my church i didn't realize that
that's what i was getting into at the
time but that's what i ended up getting
myself into but i'm the one who made the
decision
to go and live in that bad area and
while i was in that bad area i'm pretty
sure this identity theft thing happened
i think that's where my guilt is i made
a bad decision because of the bad
decision that i made it cultivated you
lived in an area where people robbed
banks
one of them robbed a bank
that does not make you responsible
for robbing a bank
because you lived in an area where
people rob banks
if you'll think of this as a bank robber
it'll help you work through the ethics
of it
yeah i hear what you're saying but it's
not okay dude go pay the bill if you
want i'm not paying the bill if i don't
owe it i'm not i'm done arguing with you
yeah okay but that
is it not a little fishy dave that he
calls the holder the bank of the credit
card and says this is me
and i'm getting bills for this i want to
see the transaction history and they
won't share it with him that seems a
little squishy weird to me well that's
yeah it is weird
something's not adding up and then he
feels like he's got to die on this hill
here so i
and how do you 99.9 the point one i i i
think he's 100 sure that he didn't take
it out i think he is
i think he's 100 sure that he didn't do
this but he still feels like he has to
do it for some reason i don't know where
that's coming from
it's it's it is not an integrity issue
listen if you call this show and tell me
you don't want to pay a bill that you
owe i'm gonna i'm gonna be all over your
butt for integrity okay i do it all the
time and i have for 30 years but when
someone steals your identity you are not
responsible under any scenario for that
just because you lived in an area where
identity thieves live
i mean
if you live in canada and there's an
attorney there in canada that's trying
to rip somebody off on a 13 million
dollar scam are you liable because you
live in canada no you're not this is
just that's just absurd